hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to episode 3 of drunk
minecraft season 2 I'm still here with
Bob and way to introduce yourselves
please go ahead bob my name is bob i'm
my scam follow me on twitter i have a
twitter i'm Wade Lord minion 777 I have
a Twitter but I have a youtube - under
the same name oh yeah more impressive
yeah
ok alright that's great um so yeah here
we are
oh no stern night here we are with these
giant blank template statues of a
Minecraft persona and we've still got
our clock there so Bob is above this one
way is above this one and there are many
like it nism above this one what we're
going to do since Wade was the
incredible and amazing winner of last
episodes game we are going to honor his
victory by making statues in his image
and the closer they are to how he really
looks the better or not I'm not really
sure it's up to zombie to judge who is
the winner but we have a whole rainbow
spectrum of wool here we are going to
use the [ __ ] ah okay person who has
skin color ie got birch wood planks
birch wood planks oh sorry you're still
dying the zombie kill me Oh iron armor
on down here oh okay so now that that is
out of the way and everybody is dying
maybe we could turn it today or
something magical sky camera not really
Bob Ewell shears are on top of your head
oh okay can I get done with the intro
please I'm trying to explain the rules
here oh okay we have 20 minutes in order
to build the best way that we can are
you ready gentlemen yes Bob do you have
your stuff I'm reorganizing it but oh
whoa there's a load of creepers at my
feet I know just don't go to a okay
we're good just good we're good all
right Bob once you are on top of your
head we will be getting to go in the
gonna sprit Iman what she said
yeah and uh what are you drinking there
Wade still Yingling I'm still drinking
grape vodka and grape soda I'm still on
my fourth I called it after the last one
so uh I'm still good I'm ready I saw up
have anything that's tan colored so
birch wood planks you get him later Bob
what are you drinking are you are you
done
I look up he's out of bourbon bourbon
but I still have leg
he still has drunk okay all right on
there you can see that I've got like
have a glass of bourbon and coke all
right that's nice okay so we are ready
yeah ready we are going to begin when I
count down so begin no I'll begin in 3 2
go go go go go Oh elmo's fell to death
oh no wait I can't die ok all right so
uh let's see what we're gonna do here my
god I'm already awful Oh how in the hell
is this supposed to happen now how did
you lose already ah you can shear slower
when you're flying this is not helping
okay alright whatever I'll get this
let's see uh way do you have purple
pants right sounds yep chaps at the
chaps take their assless chaps assless
chaps okay I can oh yeah that sounds
like a good deal you yeah weight or
light weight right Bob you need to shear
off then put wool down
oh I'm building on top of Oh does it on
it so this is happening now
I'm hoping this mine will get saved as a
template for years to come I think as
punishment whoever loses the worst ha ha
ha
create the skin and wear it in the next
episode end up making they should have
to go oh no I'm still gonna make my the
way
thank very carefully about their outfits
oh oh I don't I don't even care anymore
I'm going for it all the way oh it's
gonna be so great
oh no I'm already at a button aha
all right there Bob you all right you're
doing okay no bob has had a lot to drink
oh uh uh wait has not wait is not nearly
as drunk as the rest of us here yeah I'm
good oh I always am go try not get some
burgerking after this or maybe white
mantle
oh wait that means I am trash doesn't it
haha ya know some a few episodes in the
first season of drunk minor if people
thought that I was like the least drunk
of them all when in fact I was
excessively drunk compared to everyone
else yeah like they was more sober the
drunker he gets wait what yeah what what
I know
oh I confuse me - mind blown what what
what oh [ __ ] you wait
Jesus Christ okay anyway so or yellow
wool I'm already having trouble making
my stuff symmetrical and I get a
replenish of yellow please yellow
are you building your really a freakin
crown why why is it badi this is my
template this is not you are not king of
anything anything I need I need the baby
s comes out when you have an afro whoa
like nice be wicked you did wait did
have an afro that is awesome predicted
the past ha ha ha ha orga not it ha ha
ha predicting the future no I predicted
the best but then you predicted the
future by making a bald yeah and a
future ha
well because it's true is it is it true
Wade I don't know is it Sam realization
oh clock
riff maybe this is about to get really
depressing
hit it Wade hahahahaha
uh-oh your hair just can't be shaped
like a Devo hat except it's gonna be
brown and not red I could make it red no
I'll make it brown if anyone out there
knows what the Devo hats are that's what
I'm doing
you like you do it you like it so far
away yeah do you like it so far
oh god I love it so much it's not even
half done that's not even the best part
oh good it's good do you like how your
crotch has a handlebar mustache oh okay
all right okay camera calm down I need
to concentrate on this one I'm working
on the ass part of the assless chaps
have anything to make tan skin with get
magic flying camera in the sky birch
wood all right how do you like your hair
wait I got I got she ha ha it's a helmet
it's a hair of it I don't think - Shira
before it what's up oh yeah that would
it get that far in my wait no we were
telling you that after you place like
five wool well it was too late I'm not
undoing still okay all right okay that
makes sense I honor your commitment you
know oh I guess I really don't need
white wool class oh no no please give me
something tan is there anything tan
colored yes I've been screaming birch
wood blanks [ __ ] wait yeah I know I'm
asking the magical camera in the sky Oh
birch wood is there anything that is tan
colored
Oh God oh good thing this is labeled
historic minecraft because people would
never figure that out yeah yeah it would
just be like man these guys are [ __ ]
dumb watch that who who are they gonna
watch come on whoever I want to call out
as a youtuber whoo whoo go watch yeah me
mash yeah yamimash yamimash yummy man he
was a pirate here once he was he was
I'll subscribe his channel cuz he's
[ __ ] funny destructor Bob's YouTube
yes and I have like almost honor
subscribers right now that's not good
just so you know I don't have any videos
yeah hey this isn't symmetrical how am I
supposed to make it W oh my god mrs. P
idea was this this is why I've always
said that Bob is the funniest of anyone
I've ever met especially when he's drunk
I
it's just comedic genius every single
second hey you so much you're just yeah
I didn't understand that Skype Carl
what'd you say I so much okay alright
good good
glad to shoot you in your dick if you
had one oh wait wait gonna have one in a
few minutes here and at least we'll
least one oh god how much time do we
have left
look at the clock e minutes no really
I'm not
honey I need to look this is not even
cool I need more time I'm just working
on the ass
alright the ass is just about done a
right looks good looks good let's see
yeah yeah that's good wait no one more
little more a little more there we go
okay uh Wade you want to see go see what
your ass kind of hangs a bit low as to
oh there your ass kind of hangs a bit
low you like it you like you wait
Beautiful's good that's good okay
alright everything I'm gonna like guy
who flies from episode one huh what's
his name the guy who owns Anakin before
me what mod race I'm talking about judge
just terrifying
what oh my god I don't even know what
you guys are talking about we're barely
Donna we don't have enough time to back
around gotta get serious up in here up
and up in her up and jaw are you all
gonna make mark loose is mine up in here
up in here up in here yeah Wade you
didn't did you shave off the front layer
before you started putting down yeah
looking good
Arya's it second just check I'm the only
one who didn't do that mark okay all
right just jacket just checking just
checking all right let's see this is
gonna be a masterpiece Wade you're gonna
love this
yeah okay I'll bet let's see you're
gonna have big pink luscious red
luscious lips oh god you're gonna look
good all right let's see here let's see
damn it I got like a web okay what it
went on his shoulder wanna I don't know
you okay there Bob be okay Runk I guess
that's the whole thing could be you
never know
Oh where's your eyes gonna be that's way
too big for a mouth ah whatever let's go
with it
yes Oh God ah I decided in to save time
I'm only doing the front and then we'll
see if I get around to the rest of it
I'm a doctor do any more in the back
besides those assless chaps so you're
safe Wade
Xabi I need an axe too stupid wood Oh
God okay alright
is it in the wrong spot crap I didn't
plan slips are two big [ __ ] we're
gonna be red were than me oh no this is
skin around the lips call then then the
lips come in oh I just had like the best
idea ever
ha ha ha ha ha nice piggy
now we name our time oh hey tuned for
part two of let's screw up Wade's body
that sounds like a horrible videos now
what's still a Minecraft series I don't
know yeah Cheers do not share fastest
are really flying
wait you're not paying attention to be
laughing maniacally I play attention so
it's time to look ha ha ha ha oh oh and
you do look oh it's so great yeah look
what I want to finish my statue ha ha ha
you haven't looked yet Bob okay that's
okay don't look at - just kiss it's me
yeah ha ha ha we're really getting into
the realism of it yes yes getting a bit
more accurate in the wades horrible of
existing [ __ ] on solid ground you shoot
away faster yes you didn't notice that
would have been a really good thing to
know I could have told you that but I
kind of forgot yeah sorry sorry sorry my
bad my bad
oh if you didn't help us is this a
competition I've forgotten is it oh my
god
Oh Oh mistakes I love you so much
Oh Marc yeah a little time Oh
because of a penis right now ha ha ha
crying for your love of a penis ah just
so perfect it's so perfect
ok alright I'm done I'm done I'm done
I'm done I'm good now I'm good just need
to make the eyes and then we'll be ok
and yeah that's yeah it's got it yeah
pretty good yeah pretty good I like that
whoa hey dodging - flying up there we go
ok done with the face and just need to
put the finishing touches on the penis
and then at Brigid I like that that free
good did I mention that this is x-rated
drunk minecraft no no that's a bigger
put in the title
hahaha really gonna be softcore porn
hahahahaha God am I done
oh it's so wrong only now realizing this
it's so wrong
oh my god I can't show this it's just
every I'm gonna have to blur out every
angle on my video it's so bad oh oh god
no oh yeah I got get you have a chest
emblem that's right I forgot
oh this is what I do with my life
yes haha how much time we got left
ah some some some is good minutes 6
minutes oh crap I told you what's gonna
be enough time I said that it nice or
wait said that no I don't think wait
said that
even Bob admitted it he never sides with
me well I never side with you either so
what does it matter sometimes do you
show when you kill me and destroy my
house guys what would I ever do that
oh yeah last episode mm-hmm mm yes
pretty good that's really good if
there's an award for realism I'm pretty
sure I'm gonna win that one oh yeah are
you kidding me
have you seen mine yeah I've seen it I'm
pretty sure I'm gonna win that one oh
okay all right okay
okay this looks good and point point
blank blank blank poink poink poink
poink poink poink poink poink poink
poink poink yeah I guess I thought we'd
have enough time in one si si I put a
nice pink a nice heart on the front your
chest Wade looks good right looks good
it's oh god that's beautiful yeah thank
you I know should I fill it in I don't
have enough time to fill it in yeah you
should oh okay all right unless you say
so especially you don't have time well
what else could I put on here what else
could I do pants do you have uh glue
black-ish gray black I thought it was
blue but a miner blue okay never mind
I didn't realize that yours is a copy of
mine and I think it's similar uh well I
mean I've got the W which is different
from yours but yeah which is an
upside-down M no I don't think that's
true
yeah that's fresh shut up Wade I will
vote I could put more penises on here
don't tempt me probably will well now I
will
I still haven't added yours on it's just
kind of a hollow space let's see what I
could do with this one let's see yeah
let's see what color like bright orange
yeah let's get era here we go
wait wink point point point point point
point point point point how in the world
did you guys cheer fast enough point
point point point we stood on top of it
and point point good point point point
point point point point point point
that's good my dad but white is not a me
used I've done I'm done I'm building no
more oh wait look wait look wait oh my
god hahahaha
verify no no is so bad I'm literally
gonna have to I'm gonna what what
happened I'm just looking at your statue
oh that's actually happened you ride a
park that there's like no way you're
should ever win a below your entire
schedule
oh god I'm gonna be working on editing
editing it for hours just try to get it
so that it can be shown on the Internet
wait no I I should give you a handlebar
mustache too as well wait look mastering
won a matching one yes yes here we go
good the curtains match the drapes and a
nice ah what kind of hair should you
have oh let's see here
don't copy mine that's my BOB mmm no no
no no let's see um look at the Homer
Simpson here
oh look good good I like the sound of
that
poink poink poink poink poink poink
poink poink poink no not now
boink there we go got it okay oh that's
one and one should do alright one's good
enough I am done I'm just gonna ride out
the rest of this competition with me
facing the opposite direction of my
statue I'm doing two minutes less than
two minutes huh I'm looking pretty good
looking pretty good wait no Bob you're
supposed to break him down into planks
Oh hahaha way that's really fun
I've decided he is very you didn't take
care of the self where's God acting it
it's all porous and stuff oh man
yes Krishna metrical act no we're hang
on I'll help you I'll be I got an axe I
got it no I had it because I was right
there helping out today I was helping
you there shut up ha ha I love my statue
so much anima get yours good is really
[ __ ] disturbing shut up you so ah ha
ha ha ha ha ha ha ha and Siegrist
zombies you copy that put in the center
of town 100 percent certain that is not
gonna happen
I guess oh because I am a human being
ha ha ha I don't even know I don't even
know how to blur City horrible you
should just do a black ha ha ha ha ha ha
ha just foot just [ __ ] just a blonde
oh my god everything then I'd have to
hand animate it for all the times I
remember oh god I didn't get the finish
we're done we're done we're done
dyma ha I didn't get to finish my pants
ha ha ha ha Yuli wearing lederhosen I'm
pretty sure I win saying oh oh my god
ball that era
ha ha ha did you feel like I fixed the W
yeah yeah yeah y-you thought it would
come yeah you're mad no the winner is
obvious good yeah he looks so surprised
i won hahahaha
please make the wave favor with Oh into
it ahahaha l for this episode or nah oh
god is so bad oh sorry Bob did you check
out the ass on the back okay alright
okay okay alright so I won for I get to
do the outro and I will be featured in
the next video apparently oh it's so bad
I gotta put a warning at the beginning
this video okay so this has been a fun
competition thank you everybody for
watching thank you wade for joining me
and being a good sport about it thank
you Bob for joining me um subscribe to a
channel don't subscribe or follow bob on
twitter Thank You Dom B or judging this
and letting this happen um if you want
to play on the server that we're playing
on right now link is in the description
the IP is right there click on it go to
the server website its ton of fun lots
of stuff all sorts of stuff if you got a
big idea you want we're doing one idea
in episode so make it a big one like big
to do something like this
that's fun right into the comments below
so that'll do it for tonight it can be
cooperative or us pitted against each
other yes either one doesn't matter big
make it as big as you want it to be so
thank you all so much for watching click
the annotation for more videos that I've
done and as always we will see you
in the next video bye bye bye
door
Oh
but
yeah